my name is Eunice verdusco I'm the
director of membership sales at the
Sterling Club the Sterling Club is a
private exclusive Club in the city of
Las Vegas we have been reopened for the
last three years we went through a very
extensive Remodel and it's really just a
Hidden Gem for our members and
a typical typically at the Sterling club
for our members includes everything from
eating at our restaurant smoking in the
Cigar Lounge getting a facial getting
your hair done in Our Salon and Spa
going to the pool playing tennis playing
pickleball there's so many amenities
that we provide and it's just it's a
little too long to list currently we're
in our Spirits lounge and this is where
most of our live entertainment takes
place so everything that requires a
little bit of a larger setup like a band
setup takes place in here we have supper
club in here we Host movie Nights in
here and this space is also available
for private events to be a member you
don't have to be a resident of Turnberry
place you we have memberships for
corporate accounts the benefits for
corporate accounts is that they can host
their business meetings here their
holiday parties we're a great place and
a great source for businesses to conduct
networking events also just a lot of
organic networking takes place in our
club you know you can be sitting in the
Cigar Lounge and you're next to someone
a CEO of a company that you know you've
always wanted to reach out to we're a
great source for all businesses I
remember roster contained some of the
most prestigious residents and
non-residents of Las Vegas we provide
the perfect setting for you to mix and
mingle with like-minded individuals and
you know we just help in creating those
relationships that are going to be good
for your business and even for your
personal life so another benefit of
corporate accounts is they can have
their corporate meetings here big or
small meetings from 10 people to
250 people with that being said we have
corporate memberships we have individual
memberships we have young executive
memberships so whether you're a lawyer a
doctor a business a big corporate
operation a small Corporation we have
the right membership for you we also
have the Las Vegas resident membership
we have a young executive membership we
have an out-of-state membership and
Ladies If you're looking for some
self-care throughout the day this is a
great place to unwind while the kids are
at school so you can go to our website
or give us a call or if you want just
drop on by